COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WILL
COME TO ORDER- WE HAVE A- WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL NUMBER YOUR NUMBER HERE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HERE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HERE LEYVA LEYVA HERE
STERN. RIGHT WHAT AGOOD WAY TO
START THE NEW YEAR WITH A
QUORUM HERE JUST MINUTES AFTER
OUR ANNOUNCED STARTING TIME SO-
I ALSO SEE THAT THAT WE HAVE
AUTHORS HERE- WE HAVE TWO BILLS
ON OUR AGENDA TODAY IN FIRST IS
SB FIFTY SEVEN ANDERSON IS
GOING TO BE CALLED PRESENTED BY
US SENATORS BATES THAT AND MORE
LIKE THAT RIGHT. YES ALL RIGHT.
SELLERS FLOOR IS YOURS
. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN ARM I'M WEIRD I DO
HAVE A WITNESS SIGN HERE ALSO
ME THEY APPROACH INJURE. ONE
YEAH YEAH THANK YOU. WELL GOOD
MORNING ARM AND- VERY PLEASED
THAT YOU GUYS WERE HERE TO HEAR
MY BILL OF WHAT SECOND DAY OF
THE NEW SESSION SO THANK YOU-FOR THAT SB FIFTY SEVEN IS
TRULY OF FROM MY PERSPECTIVE A
VERY SIMPLE FIX TO WHAT HE IS A
COMPLICATED PROCESS THAT ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS TO OPT IN FOR VOTER
REGISTRATION OUT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
DMV INSTEAD OF AUTOMATICALLY
BEING REGISTERED TO VOTE OR
HAVING TO OPT OUT OF THE
PROGRAM. I IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE IT YOU KNOW THE FEDERAL
NAY IN ALL VOTER REGISTRATION
ACT REQUIRED EACH STATE YOU
OFFER VOTER REGISTRATION
SERVICES AT A MYRIAD OF STATE
RUN OFFICES LIKE THE DMB OR
OTHER OFFICES THAT OFFER PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE HOWEVER THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DID NOT DICTATE HOW
THAT PROCESS SHOULD OPERATE FOR
TWENTY THREE YEARS CALIFORNIA
HAD OFTEN VOTER REGISTRATION
THAT WORKED WELL AND CERTAINLY
DID NOT HAVE MAJOR ISSUES
HOWEVER IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA CHANGES MOTOR VOTER
LAW TO INSTEAD REQUIRE. VIGILS
TO ACTUALLY OPT OUT OF VOTER
REGISTRATION EVEN IF THEY HAD
PREVIOUSLY REGISTERED AND
DIDN'T NEED TO RE REGISTER AND
IT AUTOMATICALLY TRANSFERRED
THAT INFORMATION FROM THE DMV
TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE. THE INFORMATION THAT
TRANSFERRED IS NOT CHECKED FOR
ELIGIBILITY BUT AUTOMATICALLY
ADDED TO THE VOTER ROLLS AFTER
THE DMB IMPLEMENTATION IN MAY
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE PUBLIC
STARTED HEARING ABOUT. ISSUES
THAT WERE DEVELOPING THE LA
TIMES REPORTED THAT A SOFTWARE
ERA. AFFECTED SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND VOTER REGISTRATIONS IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
FACT BE REPORTED THAT THE DIEM
BE TRANSMITTED TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND AROUND THE US VOTER
REGISTRATIONS. IN OCTOBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE LA TIMES
REPORTED THAT THE STATE AGENCY
MISTAKENLY REGISTERED ANOTHER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED INELIGIBLE
RESIDENTS INCLUDING NON
CITIZENS. IN FACT SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
GROUPS TESTIFIED AGAINST AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE. BECAUSE OF
THIS EXACT CONCERNED THEY
CORRECTLY FEARED THAT
UNDOCUMENTED PERSONS WOULD BE
SWEPT INTO THE VOTER SIT DOWN
WHEN THEY WERE PERTAINING
DRIVERS ARE. BOTH IN JANUARY
TWENTY NINETEEN THE SACRAMENTO
BEE REPORTED THAT ELECTION
OFFICIALS KNEW THAT THE MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM WASN'T READY TO
BE LAUNCH AND YET- IT WENT
AHEAD ANYWAY. ALSO IN AUGUST
TWENTY NINETEEN THE ASSESSMENT
PRODUCED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOUND OUT ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND
RECORDS SHOWED A DISCREPANCY.
THE VOTERS STATED POLITICAL
AFFILIATION AN ADDITIONAL
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHT FOUR
REGISTRATIONS HAD DUPLICATES.
THE REPORT ALSO CONFIRM THAT
VOTER REGISTRATIONS ARE NOT
VERIFIED BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. STORY PUBLISHED IN THE
SACRAMENTO BEE IN AUGUST ONE
NIGHT REPORTED THAT CALIFORNIA
THE LAND. THAT WERE ADDED TO
THE ROOT VOTER ROLLS BY MISTAKE
ACTUALLY WILL BE ON THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN GENERAL. EVEN JUST
RESET LIAM. I JUST ONE MONTH
AGO DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN AT
LEAST SIX HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS
FOUND THAT THERE VOTER
REGISTRATIONS HAD BEEN
UNEXPECTEDLY CHANGE WITHOUT
THEIR CONSENT AND I WILL SHARE
WITH YOU THAT MY OFFICE
RECEIVED A NUMBER. OF
COMPLAINTS OR CONCERNS ABOUT
HOW THEY WERE CURRENTLY
REGISTERED IN WE DID DIRECT
THEM TO OUR LOCAL REGISTRAR OF
VOTERS. THESE ARE GRIEVOUS
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED BECAUSE IT'S VERY
CLEAR FROM THE LET ME THAT I'VE
SHARED WITH YOU TODAY THE MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM ISN'T WORKING OUT
THAT WAS INTENDED. EARLIER THE
SERGEANTS DISTRIBUTED TO YOU A
COPY OF SCREEN SO THE VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESS THAT THE
D. V. FROM OCTOBER TWELFTH
NINETEEN. IF YOU'LL DIRECT
ATTENTION TO JUST PAGE TWO
THIRDS AND ASKS WHAT ARE BEST
DESCRIBES YOU IN IS HERE THAT I
BELIEVE THE ERRORS REALLY OCCUR
AND CERTAINLY I IN MY OWN
EXPERIENCE IDEA GO TO GET A NEW
DRIVER'S LICENSE DECEMBER OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. ARE I WAS
CONCERNED HEARING THE PROBLEMS
THAT THERE WASN'T A BOX THERE
FOR ME TO SAY I DON'T NEED TO
REGISTER I AM REGISTERED AND
YOU KNOW LET ME GO ON TO THE
REST OF THE APPLICATION THERE
IS NOTHING. THAT WE ON THERE
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO DO THAT I
ACTUALLY CHECKED THE SECOND BOX
WHICH SAYS. I AM REGISTERED TO
VOTE AND WANT TO UPDATE MY
VOTER REGISTRATION INFORMATION
JUST BECAUSE THAT WAS THE ONLY
THING THAT CAME CLOSE. TO MY
PARTICULAR SITUATION I'VE BEEN
JUST. TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD. AND
ARE ARE THAT CAME BACK TO ME
AFTER I CHECKED THAT BOX IT
BASICALLY SAID YOU'RE NOW
REGISTERED AS ROOT. CANALS OF
DECEMBER TWENTIETH NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND I BEEN
REGISTERED LIKE I SAID SINCE
WAY BACK IN TWO YEARS AGO. SO.
IF WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
READ SURE NOT. BE I THINK WE
NEED TO DO. SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T COMPROMISE THE
INTEGRITY OF INTEGRITY OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. HAS LAW I
THINK THAT THE SIMPLE. SOLUTION
HERE IS JUST OUT OF FOURTH
BULLET TO THAT PAGE TO THAT
SAYS I AM ALREADY REGISTERED TO
VOTE PLEASE DO NOT EDIT OR
CHANGE MY CURRENT REGISTRATION
I'M COMFORTABLE OR I'M HAPPY
WITH THAT HOWEVER YOU WANT
THAT. TO ME THAT IS THE
SIMPLEST FIX TO SOMETHING IS
CREATED HAVOC ARE WITH THE
REGISTRATION SYSTEM IN IN OUR
STATE AND I'M NOT HERE TO BLAME
ANYBODY I THINK YOU KNOW WE ALL
KNOW THE COMPUTERS DO WHAT THEY
DO. ARE WE HAVE PROBLEMS IN OUR
OWN PERSONAL LIVES BUT THIS
PARTICULAR COMPUTER PROGRAM IN
PARTICULAR SCREENSHOT DUST
DOESN'T MATCH WHAT PEOPLE WANT
TO SAY. ABOUT THAT PRESSURES
ARE. ITEM THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE AND TO VOTE IN
THE PARTY OF PREFERENCE EMAIL
PREFERENCES. ARE AND OUT
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS VERY
VERY SACRED AND WE SHOULD
HONOR- EACH INDIVIDUAL AND THIS
IS NOW NO ATTEMPT IN ANY
FASHION. DO NOT GET PEOPLE TO
REGISTER TO VOTE WE WERE
HANDLING COMPLAINTS FROM ALL
PEOPLE IN OUR DISTRICT WHETHER
THEY WERE IN P. P. DEMOCRAT
REGISTRANT OR REPUBLICAN. AND
THEY ALL HAVE CONCERNS SO I
THINK IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE
DO SOMETHING ODD TO FIX THE
SYSTEM AND WITHOUT. I AM VERY
PLEASED TO HAVE SENATOR MORE
LOCK- TO TESTIFY ON ISSUES THAT
HE HAS FOUND WITH THIS AND ARE
HERE TO STAY. AND DANCE MORE OF
THE INSTITUTE FOR FAIR
ELECTIONS IS JOINING ME TO GIVE
HER COMMENTS. YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COLLEAGUES FIRST OF ALL I
JUST WANT TO SAY MISTER CHAIR.
YOU LOOK GREAT. I'M JUST
FOLLOWING YOUR LEAD RIGHT RIGHT
SO HANDSOME I'M SO IMPRESSED.
SO WE CALL THE ROLL. LEADING
THE WITNESS TO SAY. I AM
PLEASED TO JOIN SENATOR BATES
SAYS CO AUTHOR OF SB FIFTY
SEVEN IN THE PRESENT THIS BILL
TO YOUR COMMITTEE- AS A
NATURALIZED U. S. CITIZEN ARE
YOU BELIEVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE
IS VERY SACRED SO THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO ME- IT IS
EXTREMELY. EXTREMELY DISTURBING
THAT THE MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM IS
A MESS. THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PROGRAM WAS RUSHED AND
PREMATURE. AND NOW TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
BEEN INCORRECTLY REGISTERED TO
VOTE. THIS SERIOUS MISTAKE HAS
PLACED THE INTEGRITY OF
CALIFORNIA SELECTIONS AT STAKE.
I STARTED GETTING A LOT OF
CONSTITUENTS. REQUEST BACK IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO ON THE
BREAK IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN I PULL UP HERE AND I
MET PERSONALLY WITH ALEX VIDEO.
OUR SECRETARY OF STATE AND I
SAID I'M I'M GETTING A LOT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM IN APRIL AND WE
WENT THROUGH A LONG. DISCUSSION
IN HIS OFFICE ON HOW EVERYTHING
WOULD BE FINE EVERYTHING WAS
TAKEN CARE OF THERE WOULD BE
NO. NO GIPSON GAPS SERVER OR
FAUX PAS- BUT YET WITHIN MONTHS
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF MOTOR
VOTER- WE STARTED SEEING A LOT
OF ISSUES AND NEWSPAPER REPORTS.
EVEN AFTER BEING ASSURED THAT
EVERYTHING WOULD BE FINE WITH
WITH SHORTLY AFTERWARDS TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND RONI'S MOTOR
VOTER REGISTRATIONS WERE FOUND
AND FROM THAT POINT I AM I'VE
I'VE JUST BEEN VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE INTEGRITY OF THE
PROCESS AND I WROTE MISTER
PURDY AND SAID. WE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION YOU A SHIRT MADE
THAT THIS WOULD NOT OCCUR. AND
NOW IN FACT IT HAS. AND THE
ONGOING DISCOVERIES OF END OF
IT MALFUNCTIONS ARE MADDENING
THE ARTICLES ARE IN THIS AYE I
WAS. EMAILING WITH ONE
CONSTITUENT YESTERDAY AND EYES
HE SENT ME AN ARTICLE I SAID
THANK YOU AND THEN HE'S LIKE
BUILD UP MY WEBSITE OR MY WITH
MY TERMINAL PAGE WITH ALL AN
ARTICLE ARTICLE ARTICLE ARTICLE
JUST. GOES ON IT'S EMBARRASSING
FOR THE STATE TO HAVE HAD
SOMETHING LIKE THIS OCCUR WITH
SB FIFTY SEVEN IT OFFERS A
COMMONSENSE APPROACH TO REMEDY
THIS CRITICAL PROBLEM WITH THE
MOTOR VOTER REGISTRATION
PROCESS. A SIMPLE OPT OUT
OPTION. RATHER THAN AN OPT. OUT
OPTION. WILL HAVE HELPED
PREVENT ANOTHER CRITICAL BREACH
OF OUR ELECTION SYSTEM. VOTERS
TO SELF CERTIFY THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE WILL HELP
ESTABLISH MORE ACCOUNTABILITY
IN THE ELECTION PROCESS. AND
HELP CREATE ADDITIONAL
SAFEGUARDS. SB FIFTY SEVEN WILL
PREVENT FUTURE REGISTRATION
MISTAKES AND RESTORE VOTER
CONFIDENCE IN THE INTEGRITY. OF
OUR ELECTIONS. MISTER CHAIR.
FOR LEGISLATORS- WE DON'T RUN
THESE DEPARTMENTS- BUT- WE'RE
THE ONES THAT ARE CONTACTED
WHEN SOMETHING GOES WRONG SO
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO. DO
LEGISLATION THAT TELLS
DEPARTMENTS HOW BEST TO-
OPERATE CERTAIN FUNCTIONS I'M
SORRY THAT THE DIRECTOR THE DMB
AND SECTOR STATE HAVING ALREADY
AND IMPLEMENTED SOMETHING. LIKE
THIS THAT MAKES IT A LITTLE
MORE USER FRIENDLY BUT I THINK
SB FIFTY SEVEN IS SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD BE PURSUING THE
SEND THE MESSAGE THAT. THIS
SHOULD BE DONE A LITTLE MORE
APPROPRIATELY BECAUSE IT
REFLECTS ON ALL HUNDRED AND
TWENTY LEGISLATORS AND BE
ELECTED STATEWIDE OFFICES SO
WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR. WITH
THE VERY DISTINGUISHED AND
HANDSOME BEARD I WOULD DOUBT.
KILEY REQUEST TO SUPPORT FOR SB
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU CENTER
MORE LOG- JUST A QUICK QUESTION
BEFORE WE TURN THE WITNESS
CENTER BATES YOU YOU SAID THIS
WOULD SIMPLY ADD A FOURTH BOX
WHAT WITH THAT FOURTH BOXY I'M
SORRY. IT WOULD SAY- I'M
ALREADY REGISTERED TO VOTE
PLEASE DO NOT EDIT OR CHANGE MY
CURRENT REGISTRATION. IN THAT
SECTION THAT ASKS WHAT BEST
DESCRIBES YOU. AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THAT SECTION IAN THAT ARE
HAND OUT AND THERE'S NOTHING
THAT BEST DESCRIBES SOMEONE.
WHO'S ALREADY REGISTERED AND
LIKES OF THE PARTY OR THE NOT
NO PARTY THAT THEY'RE IN. AND
THEY'RE READY TO GO ON THE NEXT
SHOT SCREENSHOT THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO GET A NEW DRIVER'S
LICENSE OR REGISTRATION OR
CHANGE YOUR ADDRESS WHATEVER
GOES AFTER THAT AND I WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU. CHAIRMAN ON
BURKE WHEN I WAS AT THE DMV I
WENT THERE SPECIFICALLY TO TEST
HOW WE WERE DOING AND WE WERE
DOING BETTER. I IN TERMS OF
LINES I GOT IN LINE I DIDN'T
HAVE AN APPOINTMENT SENT ME TO
THE COMPUTER TO FILL OUT THE
APPLICATION. I'M STANDING NEXT
TO AN ELDERLY GENTLEMAN AND HE
IS BACKING UP OUT OF THE HIS
LITTLE CUBICLE BECAUSE HE'S
TOTALLY CONFUSED. AND I SAID
MAY I HELP YOU SIR BECAUSE HE
WAS VERY DISTRESSED AND HE SAID
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO SO. I
AM A LIFELONG REGISTERED HE
DIDN'T TELL ME AS PARTY ANY
SAID I DON'T FIND ANYTHING UP
HERE THE LET ME TO DO THAT. ME
SO I THINK I NEED TO START OVER
AND I SAID NO WHAT YOU NEED TO
DO THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO COME
BACK AND THAT FORTY MINUTE LOT.
DO WHAT I'M DOING IT. THE THIRD
QUESTION WHICH SAYS I'D LIKE TO
UPDATE MY RESTRICTION YEAH EVEN
PLEADED SO THE QUESTION IS CAN
USING EVERYBODY. AND THERE IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO OPT OUT WITH
QUESTION AND THEN THE THIRD
QUESTION THE PHONE THERE NOW.
BUT IT IS NOT CLEAR THAT. YOU
DON'T WANT YOUR REGISTRATION
CHANGE IN ANY FASHION YOU'RE
ALREADY READ. N FULL SIMPLE TO
ME. BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
SIMPLE BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE
LEGISLATION SO AND I'VE ALREADY
SHARED THIS. STORY MANY MANY
TIMES AT HERE WE ARE. WITH THE
REGGAE XIN THAT OF THAT
ACTUALLY SAYS. ARE I WANT TO.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE REGISTERED
IN THAT. SOME THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD BE ALLOWED IN DOUBTS IN
THERE BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR WAY ON
THE SECOND PAGE AND THE TIME
THEY GET THEIR THERE THEY'RE
TOTALLY CONFUSED. YEAH I WAS
CONFUSED I'M SUPPOSED TO BE
WELL VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE IN THIS
WHOLE THING AND THE GENTLEMAN
NEXT TO ME. I WAS VERY TO USE
AND WANTING TO GO ON WITH IT SO
REGISTRATION. CONCERNED
BECAUSE- IN ME TO SPEAK TODAY
MY NAME IS AND ON SOME MORE-
AND I'M PRESIDENT OF THE
INSTITUTE FOR FAIR ELECTIONS WE
ARE FIVE OH ONE C. THREE
ORGANIZATION THAT ANALYZES AND
MONITORS THE QUALITY AND
INTEGRITY OF VOTER DATABASES
DATABASES AS YOU ALL KNOW ARE
DYNAMIC AND COMPLEX THE LARGER
THE FILE THE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE
THEY ARE TO UNINTENTIONAL
ERRORS. AND OF COURSE EXTERNAL
MANIPULATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE IN%
AS WE'VE ALREADY HEARD TODAY
I'M- IN JUNE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN PRIMARY IN CALIFORNIA
AS MANY AS SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND. OF VOTERS IN THE
STATE SYSTEM OR AN ADVERT LEAD
DUPLICATED BY THE DMV AND LA
COUNTY. ALSO IN THAT SAME
PRIMARY A HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND VOTERS WERE LEFT OFF A
FREESYNC ROSTERS. DUE TO EMERGE
ERROR. A HUNDRED THE THOUGHT I
THINK IT'S CLOSER TO HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND HAD POLITICAL
PARTY MISTAKES OR RE
ATTRIBUTIONS. MANY STUDIES OVER
TIME AND I WILL CITE THE CAL
TECH AND MY TEA VOTING
TECHNOLOGY PROJECT REPORT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE- THAT THEY
DID WITH ORANGE COUNTY- MANY
STUDIES OVER TIME HAS SHOWN
THAT GENERATING AUDIT DATA IS
NECESSARY TO EVALUATE VOTER
FILE QUALITY AND ALEXIAN
INTEGRITY. AUDIT DATA ALSO
SERVES TO HELP IMPROVE
ADMINISTRATION PRACTICES. KEEP
IN MIND THAT AUDITS DO NOT JUST
NEED TO HAPPEN AFTER THE FACT
THEY COULD AND SHOULD BECOME
PART OF A DAILY PROCESS MAYBE
EVEN MINUTE BY MINUTE.
CALIFORNIA CAME LATE TO THE
GAME COMPARED TO OTHER STATES
WITH CENTRALIZED WITH A
CENTRALIZED VOTER DATABASE WE
ARE BIG STATE. AND PROBABLY
NEEDED THAT TIME- I BELIEVE
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TEN AND
FIFTEEN YEARS AFTER THE INITIAL
STATES- INCORPORATED AND
COMPLIED WITH THAT- MANDATE
WITH ALL THAT TIME THE WRINKLES
WERE CLEARLY NOT IRONED OUT
BEFORE LAUNCH. THIS ALONG WITH
THE MOTOR VOTER OR WITH- VOTER
THAN ASSN SAME DAY REGISTRATION
AND SOON VOTE CENTERS MATE WILL
MAKE FOR TSUNAMI OF PROBLEMS
AND ALREADY HAVE THAT SEEM TO
CONSTANTLY COME TO LIGHT THERE
IS ENORMOUS PRESSURE ON COUNTY
REGISTRARS TO KEEP UP. AND THIS
MAKES FOR PROCESS THAT FOR NOW
SEEMS TO BE DEPENDENT ON THE
HONOR SYSTEM. THE PROBLEMS WE
HAVE FOUND THAT I FE. STARTED A
VERY FUNDAMENTAL LEVEL WHY ARE
THERE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE OVER THE AGE OF A
HUNDRED AND SIX WHICH AT LAST
LOOK WAS THE OLDEST AGE OF. OF
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA ON THE
VOTER ROLES IS IT DEAD PEOPLE
VOTING OR MERELY THE QUALITY.
OF THE DATA MAINTENANCE WE
FOUND THAT IT WAS THE LATTER.
WIRE LAWSUITS LIKE THE ONE THAT
WAS RECENTLY WON BY JUDICIAL
WATCH IN LOS AGELES COUNTY-
WHY DID THEY HAPPEN WHERE THEY
FIND TWENTY FIRST WHEN THEY END
UP HAVING TO REMOVE TWENTY
PERCENT. OF THOSE REGISTERED
THAT THERE WERE A HUNDRED AND
44% OF THE ELIGIBLE RESIDENTS
REGISTERED. TO VOTE. SO WILL
TAKE YEARS AND MILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO ASSESS AND
THEN FIX THIS PROBLEM. THERE
MUST BE FILTERS SUCH AS THOSE
ADDRESSED IN SB FIFTY SEVEN. IN
MY VIEW SB FOUTS FIFTY SEVEN SO
IT'S FOR SAFEGUARDS ALMOST AN
AUTOMATED FILTERING AN AUDIT
MECHANISM WHICH IS SO VERY
CRITICAL TO ANY FORM OF
INTEGRITY IN ALL FORMS OF DATA
GATHERING. IT MOST CERTAINLY
WILL SLOW DOWN INTERNAL QUALITY
DETERIORATION. WE NEED MORE OF
THESE TYPES OF STOP GAPS WITH
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS WE CAN
PREVENT PROBLEMS INSTEAD OF
WAITING TO FIND THEM IN AN
AUDIT. MOST IMPORTANTLY THESE
FILTERS PROTECT NOT JUST THE
INTEGRITY OF THE ROLES BUT
CLEARLY DEFINES THE INTENT OF
THE VOTER. IT'S AN INTEGRITY
TRY FACTOR THAT PROTECTS THE
VOTERS ASSIST THE STATE. AND
ALLEVIATES UNDUE STRESS ON THE
COUNTIES WE HOPE THAT SB FIFTY
SEVEN IS THE BEGINNING. IN NEW
LEGISLATION TO RESTORE
INTEGRITY TO THE VOTER ROLLS IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE. OPPOSITION
. MORNING.
JAMES TWELVE ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY STATE ALEX PADILLA.
AS THE COMMITTEE NOW SAYS AND
THE AUTHOR'S NOTE THE MOTOR
VOTER ROLL OUT EXPERIENCED
SEVERAL ISSUES- BUT THESE
ISSUES HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED. OUR
OFFICE HAS WORK COLLABORATIVELY.
WHAT THE NAME BE TO IMPLEMENT
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
INDEPENDENT AUDIT OF MOTOR
VOTER CONDUCTED BY ERNST AND
YOUNG LAST YEAR. WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT AUTOMATIC VOTER
REGISTRATION AT THE DMV IS A
POWERFUL TOOL TO STRENGTHEN OUR
DEMOCRACY. SINCE THE LAUNCH THE
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM NEARLY
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN REGISTER
TO VOTE. INCLUDING ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION NEW RESTAURANTS.
THANKS TO THE MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM AS WE ENTER TWENTY
TWENTY. WE HAVE A RECORD TWENTY
MILLION PLUS REGISTER VOTERS.
OVER 80% OF OUR ELIGIBLE VOTERS
ARE REGISTERED TO VOTE THE
HIGHEST RATE SINCE NINETEEN
FIFTY TWO. CALIFORNIA MOTOR
VOTER HAS BEEN A TRIMS
TRANSFORM SUCCESS FOR DEMOCRACY.
SB SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN WOULD
UNDERMINE THAT SUCCESS WHICH IS
WHY SECRETARY PERIOD STRONGLY
OPPOSES SB FIFTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS BERNICE
DOWNSIDE FOR ANIMAL VOTING
RIGHTS ATTORNEY WITH THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA IS HELIO AND
LEAVE WOMEN VOTERS ARE PART OF
A GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS THAT
SPENT A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME WORKING WITH THE SECRETARY
OF STATE AND THE DMV LEADING TO
THE ROLL UP WITH A NEW ROLL OUT
OF THE NEW MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM.
OUR WORK WAS AIMED AT ENSURING
THAT THE PROGRAM'S LANGUAGE
RELATED TO VOTER ELIGIBILITY
AND THE VOTER REGISTRATION
PROCESS WAS AS CLEAR AS
POSSIBLE. LANGUAGE TESTING
INCLUDED FOCUS GROUPS LED BY
DESIGN EXPERTS TESTING WAS DONE
AND MULTIPLE LANGUAGE LANGUAGES
AND TRANSLATIONS WERE REVIEWED
BY COMMUNITY MEMBERS. AS A
RESULT THE CURRENT NEW MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM HAS BEEN
THOUGHTFULLY DESIGNED TO
PREVENT THE IN ELIGE INELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING PLACED ON
VOTER ROLLS. CURRENTLY WITH
VOTERS REACH THE VOTER
REGISTRATION PORTION OF A
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR ID CARD
APPLICATION THE VERY FIRST
QUESTION THERE ASKED IS WHETHER
THERE SAID AS- IF THE ANSWER NO
OR DECLINE TO ANSWER THEY'RE
NOT PRESENTED WITH ANY FURTHER
VOTER REGISTRATION QUESTIONS.
EVEN AFTER A MOTOR CONFIRMS OF
THEIR US DESCENT THEY MUST AND
AFFIRM UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY
THAT THEY MEET ALL VOTER
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS AGAIN
IF ENTER NO CLIENT STATE
THEY'RE NOT PRESENTED WITH ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS. WELL THE NEW
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM DID
EXPERIENCE TECHNICAL ISSUES
DURING ITS INITIAL ROLLOUT THE
DMV IN THE SECRETARY OF STATE
HAVE NOW INVESTED SUBSTANTIAL
RESOURCES TO RESOLVE THOSE
ISSUES AND SHARP THE FUNCTIONS
OF THE NEW MOTOR VOTER SYSTEM
THAT PREVENT REGISTRATION OF
INELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS. THE
NOTION THE ATTIC VOTER
REGISTRATION AT THE DMV AND
ROADS THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTIONS IS SIMPLY UNFOUNDED.
THE REALITY IS THAT THIS
PROGRAM HAS ALREADY MADE
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS AND
CLOSING VOTER REGISTRATION
GAPS. AND MAKING OUR ELECTORATE
MORE REPRESENTATIVE FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR NOVA. THANK YOU- I
NEGLECTED TO CALL FOR THOSE
OTHERS OTHERS IN SUPPORT. OF
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. OKAY
OPPOSITION ANEEL ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU APPROACH A
MICROPHONE THIS MONEY IS CITY
WHEREVER OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE CHAIR PACIFICA PARTY
CALIFORNIA- AS A PARTY THAT
SUFFERED FROM SOME THE-
REPRESSIVE LAWS THAT WE DO HAVE
IN CALIFORNIA. I HAVE TO SAY
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE OPPOSE THIS
PARTICULAR BILL BECAUSE WE GOAL
THAT. YOUR VOTE AND NOT LESS
AND THIS WILL RESTRICT THE
NUMBER OF VOTERS SO WE WERE
OPPOSED YOU. AIR CARRIERS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND OPPOSITION. YOU. GOOD
MORNING MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING SANDRA
FOREVER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
OPPOSED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS MITCH SNIDER
WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING KAREN JONES THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS A
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU- IN BEFORE WE TURN MEMBERS
JUST ONE TECHNICAL QUESTION IT
WHEN YOU GO TO THE DMV AND IF
YOU DON'T ANSWER THE QUESTION
WHICH BEST DESCRIBES IF YOU
DON'T CHECK ON THE BLOCKS CAN
YOU NOT PROCEED TO THE
REMAINDER THE APPLICATIONS THAT
REQUIRE TO ANSWER. EACH
QUESTION ON EACH ONE OF THEM
ANSWER OKAY ALL RIGHT LET ME
TURN TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS. OF THE CENTER
NIELSEN AND. WHAT COULD YOU
TELL US THAT THE SECTOR STATE
IS DOING TO ADDRESS THE- VOTER
ROLLS VERIFY THEM TO. OUR ARE
YOU DO YOU HOW DO YOU CHECK.
AND WHAT AMOUNT OF TIME DOES IT
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE THE SAME DAY
VOTING REGISTRATION HOW HOW DO
YOU PROCESS THAN THAT.
PARTICULAR VOTER TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE IN FACT ELIGIBLE TO
VOTE AND WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO
CLEAN UP THE ROLES. AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS WOULD BE
PROCESSING THE SAME DAY VOTER
ENTRANCE. AND WOULD BE PROCESS
AT THE END OF THE CAMPUS AFTER
POINT PLACE BALLOTS AND OPEN
ABOUT SEVEN PROCESS AND- OFFICE
LIKE ANY OTHER VOTER
REGISTRATION YOU'D FIND SEE IF
THERE'S A MATCH- THERE'S A
MATCH YOU'D MATCH THAT RECORDS
THE REGISTRATION. THERE'S NOT A
MATCH. I WOULD BE A NEW VOTER
ON THE RULES. IS THAT BEING
DONE. US IN REGISTRATION WAS
WROTE ON TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
THAT'S MY UNDERSTAND IS HOW
IT'S BEEN ROLLED ON THE
COUNTIES. BUT I UNDERSTAND-
SOME CHALLENGES IN IN COUNTY
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES. THAT THEY
ARE NOT COMPLYING IS THAT
CORRECT SOME EVEN ARE UNDER
COURT ORDER. NOT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE NO NOT YOUR KNOWLEDGE
WHAT WHAT IS A SECTOR STATE
DOING TO VERIFY AND MAKE SURE
THESE ROLES ARE. AS UP TO DATE.
OKAY ENGLISH OFFICIALS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MAINTENANCE
AND UPKEEP OF- THE VOTER ROLLS
KNOWN AS WITH MAINTENANCE ARE
WE PROVIDE INFORMATION TO THE
COUNTIES- FROM STATEWIDE
AGENCIES SUCH THE DMV SO
SKIRMISH CREATION- PART OF
CORRECTIONS. TO SEND TO THE
COUNTIES AND THE USER
INFORMATION UPDATE THEIR LISTS
WHETHER TO UPDATE ADDRESSES-
WHETHER TO CANCEL REGISTRATIONS
WHETHER TO MOVE THEM TO AN
ACTIVE. ANOTHER GROUP WAS
APPARENT LAWSUITS IN THE-
NOTICED THAT THERE ARE NINETEEN
COUNTIES. THE ELEVEN OF
NINETEEN COUNTIES THAT HAVE
BEEN FOUND NATIONWIDE ARE
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES THAT ARE
PROBLEMATIC. HOW WOULD YOU
EXPLAIN THAT. I WOULD COMMON
LITIGATION BUT IN TERMS OF WHAT
I'VE SEEN ON MEDIA REPORTS-
THEY OFTEN FLAYED THE INACTIVE
VOTER FILE WITH THE ACTIVE
VOTER FILE AND ENACTED A FIRE
OR ARE VOTERS WHO YOU ARE NOT
ON THE VOTER ROLLS THEY DON'T
RECEIVE THE- OF INFORMATION
GUIDE DON'T GET ABOUT MAIL TO
THEM. AND WHEN YOU ADD IN THE
NOT DEVOTED TO THE ACTIVATOR
FOUNDING THAT'S WHERE THOSE
ACCUSATIONS COME FROM- BUT
ENACTED VOTER FILE IS SOMETHING
WHERE VOTERS ARE FOUND TO
POSSIBLY BE HAVE MOVED TOWARD
TO BEEN DECEASED OR OTHERWISE
AN ELIGIBLE BUT THEY CAN'T FOR
THE MATCH THE RECORD- THEY PUT
ON THE INACTIVE FILE FOR
CERTAIN TIME- THAT'S MY- ANY
WHAT THOSE ACCUSATIONS. STEM
FROM. WELL YOU KNOW WE GET THE
SAME ROUTE. CALLS IN OUR
OFFICES THAT HAVE BEEN CITED
HERE BY THE AUTHORS. AND WITH
MANY PRESS STORIES OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS SINCE MOTOR
VOTER A PROBLEMS. ARE YOU
DENYING THAT THERE ARE PROBLEMS.
NO THE SAID MY TESTIMONY- WE
CAN DOLLARS AT THE WERE ISSUES
WITH THE ROLLOUT- WITH MOTOR
VOTER- THOSE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED- WE'RE WORKING TO
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE ERNST AND YOUNG REPORT
FROM LAST YEAR- AND WE ALSO
ENCOURAGE- MEMBERS AND THE
MEDIA IF YOU HAVE- CONSTITUENTS
OR FOLKS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
STATUS OF THE REGISTRATION TO
REACH OUT TO OUR OFFICE. REACH
OUT THE COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS OFFICE AND WE CAN GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF. AN ISSUE THEY
MAY BE EXPERIENCING. WHAT ABOUT
THE TRUST IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES. WERE IN
TRUSTING TO ONE OF THE MOST
TROUBLED AGENCIES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THIS SACRED
RESPONSIBILITY. AND THEY
CLEARLY HAVE NOT BEEN UP TO THE
TASK. ISN'T THAT A CONCERN. IN
TERMS OF THE MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM- LIKE I SAID WE WERE
FRUSTRATED BY THE ROLL OUT
ISSUES- MOTOR VOTER BUT AS OF
TODAY THE MOTOR VOTER PROGRAMS
WORKING AS INTENDED AND
SUCCESSFUL. WHAT COULD HAVE
BEEN DONE. IN THE ORIGINAL
STATUTE. TO PREVENT SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT OCCURRED IN THE
ROLLOUT ANYTHING. I CAN THINK
OF SOMETHING IN THE STATUTE NO.
SO WHAT IS IT JUST INCOMPETENCE
OF. COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICES IN
THE SECTOR STATES OFFICES HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THIS I WOULD
THINK THE- FOR LOOKING BACK ON
HIS MEN DIFFERENTLY IT WAS THE
LAUNCH OF MULTIPLE THINGS- IN
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT WAS
THE BRAND NEW- ELECTRONIC
DRIVER'S LICENSE FORM ONLINE-
OPTIONS AT THE DMV. AS WELL AS
MOTOR VOTER. I THINK THAT'S
WHERE THOSE ISSUES CAME FROM
THE LAUNCH OKAY. WELL YOU HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND THERE'S A CLOUD
OF AND- ABOUT INTEGRITY AT OVER
THE WHOLE PROCESS YET AND TODAY.
HENCE THE BILL ENHANCE
CONCERNED ENHANCE LAWSUIT SO
I'M NOT COMFORTED THAT WE SOLVE
ALL OF OUR PROBLEMS YET. THANK
YOU AS THEIR NIELSEN THANK US
SENATOR HERTZBERG QUESTIONS YES
SIR THANK YOU VENTURA. ON. YOU
KNOW THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH FOR A
LONG TIME THE BROADER ISSUE OF
JUST MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY
IN SOCIETY WHO HAS THE ABILITY
TO VOTE IN THE ELIGIBILITY OF
ALL VOTES MAKE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IT UNDERMINES THE
FRAMEWORK OF OUR DEMOCRACY WE
ALL TALK ABOUT THIS GREAT
DEMOCRACY IN THE FOR AND WE
HAVE- THE PARTICIPATION LEVELS
AT A IT AREAS SPECIAL DISTRICT
IN THE COMMUNITIES ARE PRESENT
8% TURNOUT YOU KNOW I WE HAVE A
CORPORATION THE- UNDER THE LAW
UNLESS YOU- HAVE A CERTAIN-
MINIMUM NUMBER OF PARTICIPATION
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE A QUORUM
NECESSARY TO CONDUCT BUSINESS.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN TRYING FOR
MANY YEARS WHETHER IT'S THE
SAME DAY OR WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS
OF THE DAVIS ADMINISTRATION DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO ENHANCE
OF DISSIPATION MOTOR VOTER HAS
BEEN SOMETHING THAT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL CERTAIN TALKED
ABOUT FOR A LONG TIME AND
TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE IS PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY IN TERMS OF THE
STATE'S NUMBERS- BUT I SEE A
DISCONNECT BETWEEN WHAT SENATOR
BATES TALKS ABOUT HERE IN WHAT
THE- LARGER ARGUMENT IS AGAINST
THIS NOTION ABOUT. XIN AIR THE
GOAL PARTY MISSTEPS TRUST IN
THE DMV WHEN IN FACT WHAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US SO I JUST
ACTUALLY DO THIS ONLINE THE
OTHER DAY AND TRY TO GET MY-
THE LADY. AT TO THIS DAY I
THINK OVER THE WEEKEND. FATHER
AND SO THE QUESTION THAT YOU
RAISED PAGE TWO IS THE ISSUE OF
WHAT BEST DESCRIBES YOU AND
WHAT WHAT I GOT FROM YOU
SENATOR BATES WASN'T THAT YOU
WANT AN OPT OUT YOU JUST WANT
CLARIFICATION SO THIS SOMEBODY
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY IS IN
QUESTION IF SOMEBODY'S ALREADY
REGISTERED I'M A MOTIVATIONAL
ANY FURTHER CHANGES THAT'S AN
OPT OUT THAT SAYS I'M
REGISTERED AND SO WHAT WHAT I'M
WHAT I BUT I'M HAVING YET SOME
CHALLENGE OVER THE ANALYSIS AND
SOME CHALLENGE HERE ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO DO THIS
HAS BEEN A LARGER DISCUSSION
OVER MANY YEARS AS TO WHETHER
THERE'S FRAUD AND ALL THOSE
ISSUES AND WE CAN CITE BUT
THOSE THINGS ALL DAY LONG. BUT
WHAT I GATHER FROM YOU IS THAT
WE NEED A FOURTH BOX AS THE
CHAIRMAN SAID THE JUST SIMPLY
SAYS I'M ALREADY REGISTERED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT
RATHER THAN- I WANT TO REGISTER
I DON'T I MIGHT WANT TO
REGISTER I'VE ALREADY DONE THAT
I WANT TO REGISTER TO VOTE UP
THE VOTER REGISTRATION LIKE
CHECK THAT BOX IS A ONE. MAKE
SURE OF WAS ACCURATE THAT'S
WHAT I DID. HERTZBERG I WHY I
SAID I I'M UP THE I'M A
REGISTERED VOTER AND I'M
UPDATING IT JUST TO CHECK IT
YEAH AND THAT'S ALL THE MAKE
SHE WAS ACCURATE BECAUSE I SAYS
I DIDN'T DON'T WANT TO REGISTER
I DIDN'T CHECK THIRD BOX THAT'S
WHAT I DID BUT SO I'M TRYING TO
GET TO WHAT YOU PURPOSES HERE
IT'S ONE THING TO CLARIFY THAT
I'M ALREADY REGISTERED BECAUSE
THE IDEA HERE THE OPT OUT WOULD
HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT ON
PEOPLE REGISTERING AND THERE'S
A GREAT SENSITIVITY. IT IN THE
PROPER THE DEVOTEE THAT WE DO
ENGAGE IN YEARS THE OLD DAYS
WHEN IT WAS THIRTY DAY
REGISTRATION PEOPLE MIGHT OF
MOVED IN THEIR APARTMENT FOR
GOT TO REGISTER THAT ALSO THE
ELECTION STARTS COMING UP TO
THREE WEEKS ANOTHER ARE WE'VE
GOT THING POSSIBLE SAME DAY IN
ALL OF THESE THINGS TO ENHANCE
THE PARTICIPATION OF THE
ANYBODY'S AGAINST THAT WHAT I
WANT IS CLARITY HERE IN TERMS
OF WHAT YOU'RE REALLY SEEKING
I'M NOT SO SURE THE MESSAGE IS
DIFFERENT RIGHT. THE FATHER IS
THE US VERSUS. ADDITIONAL BAR
THE US. TRUMP THAT WE DO HERE.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG TO
THE TERRIFIED. BONTA THAT I'M
I'VE GONE KIND OF FULL CIRCLE
ON IT CENTER HERTZBERG BECAUSE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT THE FIRST
THING THE SCREENSHOT SAYS TO
YOU UNDER STATE LAW ELIGIBLE-
CITIZENS WILL BE REGISTERED TO
VOTE AND LEFT THE CHOOSE NOT TO
IN THE IN THE SECTION. OUT
WHICH BEST DESCRIBES YOU SO
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO OPT
OUT BUT AS I LOOKED AT IT I
THOUGHT FIRST OF ALL THE
CONCERN WAS DO I REALLY WANT
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES TRANSPOSON MY
INFORMATION TO SECRETARY STATE
ESPECIALLY IF I'M ALREADY
REGISTERED SO THAT WAS THE
GENESIS OF LET'S HAPPEN OFTEN
BECAUSE THAT MEANS YOU.ARE
FREE OF AND IF YOU WANT TO BE
REGISTERED- TO ARE YOU MENTALLY
I HAVE BEEN A IN PPO WANT TO
BECOME A DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN
A VERSA BUT WHEN I LOOKED AT IT
AND KEPT LOOKING AT IT REALIZE
THANKS AND FOR THE A PHYSICALLY
TO PAGE TWO IT'S CERTAINLY A
SIMPLE FIX TO PUT A BOX IN THAT
REALLY DESCRIBES YOU. THAT YOU
EITHER CAN YOU DO NOT WANT TO
REGISTER- SO YOU THAT OUR
WINDOW YOU MIGHT BE EN EL THE
PERSON WE PEOPLE NOT REGISTERED
ARE I HAD ONE AMEND ACTUALLY
CAME TO OFFICE SHE DOES NOT
WANT VOTE SHE DOUBLED. SHE DOES
TO VOTE AND APPARENTLY CHECK
THAT BOX STILL GOT RED. SO HOW
DO YOU FIX THAT WILL BE IT'S
CONFUSING BUT IF YOU HAVE A BOX
FOR THOSE WHO'VE BEEN
REGISTERED IN. ITALY ARE AND
HOW THE REGISTRATION CHANGED
IT'S A GREAT IF YOU HAVE ONE
MORE BOX WHAT THAT'S WHERE I
EVOLVED TO THAT. LET'S JUST PUT
ANOTHER BOX IN THERE AND THAT
WAY WE CAN AT LEAST MAKE THE
SYSTEM START TO WORK THE WAY IT
WAS ORIGINALLY INTENDED. DON'T
WANT TO VOTE YOU GOT A BOX FOR
THAT. THE ONE TO BE REGISTERED
I MEAN AND I'M ALREADY
REGISTERED PUT A BOX AND FOR
THAT AND PLEASE DON'T. EDIT OR
CHANGE OUR HOW WE STOP
INFORMATION FROM THE DIEM BEING
GOING TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE
THAT IS REALLY A FOUR ISSUE.
ARE THAT'S A PRIVACY ISSUE
PROBABLY ANOTHER FULL THING
BECAUSE THE BILL ACTUALLY THE
A. B. FIFTEEN THIRTY WONDER
REMEMBER THE NUMBER RIGHT
ACTUALLY REQUIRED. EVERYBODY TO
BE REGISTERED OUGHT UNLESS THEY
AFFIRMATIVELY SAID DO NOT
REGISTER AND I THINK THERE'S A
QUESTION ABOUT FORCING PEOPLE
TO BE JUST. ANOTHER ISSUE BUT
THAT'S WHAT STARTED WITH. THE
OP. RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA FIFTY
ASK FOR THE PRIME RATE. OUR I
WILL TAKE AN AMENDMENT TO THIS
BILL THAT ADDS A FOURTH BULLET
ON THE SCREEN SHOT I DON'T KNOW
THAT THAT'S- VERY DIFFICULT
VERY EXPENSIVE. I'M NOT
COMPUTER WIZARD BUT WITH SEEM
TO BE A- PART OF OUR OWN.
DOCUMENT HE QUIT WE ARE NOT A
GOOD FOR THE- INSURANCE
USUALLY. IS BECAUSE I SEE KIND
OF FINISHES IF YOU'RE SAYING I
DON'T TRUST THE D. M. V. WITH
THIS. MISSION THE TRUCK. THAT'S
A DIFFERENT. A WITH HAVING THE
DMV ENGAGE IN THE PROCESS IS
AND WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR A
LONG TIME OKAY WITH THAT. I
DON'T THINK THE RISK IS REALLY
THAT BIG. IN TERMS IN TERMS OF
THAT THAT NOTION SO. GOOD I'M
TRYING TO. GET A FINE TO THE
TUNE OF WHAT I WANNA SAY HERE'S
ONE THING TO SAY OKAY- I HAVE
NO PROBLEM WITH WITH FROM A
PUBLIC POLICY PERSPECTIVE. THAT
WE BASICALLY YOU KNOW SOME
COUNTRIES REQUIRE YOU TO
REGISTER OR SOMETHING YOU KNOW
SOME COUNTRIES REQUIRE YOU TO
VOTE WHEN I WAS TELLING PEOPLE
TO VOTE. E'RE SAYING IF YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE YOU YOU YOU AND YOU
GOT A DRIVER'S LICENSE. YOU
KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO ENHANCE THAN MOST
POPULATION TO GET REGISTERED
WITH A GOOD THING IN MY
JUDGMENT. GET THE MOST NUMBER
OF PEOPLE REGISTERED AS
WHATEVER TOOLS WE CAN DO. TO DO
THAT IS IMPORTANT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AS THEIR LEYVA. CARE
GOOD MORNING OUR I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THAT WE HAVE A VERY
ACTIVE DISTRICT OFFICE AND HERE
AT THE SACRAMENTO OFFICE WE GET
TONS OF PHONE CALLS WE RECEIVED
ABSOLUTELY NO PHONE CALLS ABOUT
THE MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM SO I
JUST WANTED TO. COUNTER THAT
NOT ALL OFFICES WERE RECEIVING
THOSE CALLS I'M IN A I JUST
ALSO WANT TO SAY I DON'T THINK
IT WAS INCOMPETENCE OF SENATOR
NIELSEN I THINK THAT ANY TIME
IN ANY ASPECT OF LIFE WHEN YOU
ROLL OUT A NEW PROGRAM THEY'RE
GOING TO BE BUGS- NO ONE
INTENTIONALLY SETS OUT TO MAKE
MISTAKES NO ONE INTENSELY SETS
OUT TO DO A BAD JOB- AND I
THINK THAT- THE SECRETARY OF
STATE HAS FIX THOSE ISSUES- AND
I JUST THINK THAT WE HAVE TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE. IN MY OLD LIFE BEFORE WAS
ELECTED ONE OF THE HARDEST
THINGS WE DID WAS TRYING TO
REGISTER PEOPLE TO VOTE AND
PEOPLE YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE BUSY
LIFE THEY JUST DON'T THEY DON'T
THINK ABOUT IT AND SO ANYTHING
THAT WE- DO TO. KEEP EASY FOR
PEOPLE TO. I IS WHAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
PUT HER OFF. AS HIS FIX THE
BUGS ARE ME. BUGS BECAUSE IT IS
A BIG PROGRAM AND YOU KNOW WHAT
THE DMV. WE CAN LOOK BACK AT
PAST ISSUES IN THE DMV BUT WE
HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO IS TRYING
TO RECTIFY THOSE ISSUES. AND
TRYING TO MAKE DMV BETTER AND I
THINK WE SHOULD LOOK TO THE
FUTURE. AND HELP IN THAT REGARD
BECAUSE DMV IS A HUGE AREA A
REFUGE A HUGE. INSTITUTION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE JUST
WANT THEM TO DO WELL BECAUSE IT
BENEFITS EVERYONE SO
UNFORTUNATELY I WILL HAVE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU SIR LIMóN UP THERE. WALK.
VERY OFTEN. GUARDING YOUR-
ASSESSMENT OF THE DMV NEW VOTER
APPLICATION. AND IN THE
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MADE A
SUGGESTION. IS THAT. IT ENHANCE
EXISTING SOLUTION WITH REAL
TIME ALIDATION OF VOTER
ELIGIBILITY USING DEFINITE
DEFINITIVE DATA. SOURCES NOW
HAS THAT BEEN DONE BY THE
SECTOR STATE THIS IS DIRECTLY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
SEVERAL THERE I THINK YOU WERE
THAT AROUND NINE OR OUR OFFICE
FOR THE DMV. YEAH YEAH. IT SAYS.
IT PRINT ENHANCE THE EXISTING
SOLUTION WITH REAL TIME
VALIDATION NOW THAT COULD BE
MAYBE THE COUNTY REGISTRARS AS
WELL I WOULD ASSUME. BUT THE
POINTING OUT A DEFICIENCY. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOT
FAMILIAR THAT ONE BLOCKING
ABOUT YOUR OFFICE ON WOULD YOU
PLEASE BECAUSE THAT'S THE KIND
OF A FUNDAMENTAL POINT HERE
THAT EVEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS ACKNOWLEDGED VERY
RECENT. JUST A FEW QUESTIONS
SEVENTY THREE FINISHED THEM A
JUST FEW QUESTIONS FIRST THE
QUESTION MISTER WHAT. YOU KNOW
ABOUT WHETHER YOU LOVE OR-
DON'T LOVE THE DMV WE HAVE NO
CHOICE DO WE DOESN'T FEDERAL
LAW MANDATES THAT WE OPERATE
MOTOR VOTER THROUGH THE DMV.
THAT CRACKED THE NATIONAL VOTER
SUPPRESSION ACT OF NINETY THREE
REQUIRES THAT THAT CAN BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REGISTER TO
VOTE. IT IS OUTSIDE OUR
JURISDICTION OUTSIDE OUR
AUTHORITY TO ACTUALLY DECIDE
ANOTHER STATE AGENCY OR EVEN A
LOCAL AGENCY HAS
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR
IMPLEMENTING- THE FEDERAL
LEGISLATION CONCERNING MOTOR
VOTERS ARE RIGHT CORRECT ALL
RIGHT. ANOTHER QUESTION- MISS
DONES WERE TESTIFIED THAT 20%
OF THE OF. VOTERS ON THE LA
REGISTER VOTERS ROLES WERE
ELIMINATED WAS AT IT A
CONSEQUENCE OF THEM BEING
INELIGIBLE TO VOTE OR WHAT. WAS
THAT'S JUST SIMPLY FOLKS IN
VOTING SOMETIME. THIS
MICROPHONE I'M SORRY EVERY
FIND. ON IT THEY FOUND THAT THE
FIRST OF ALL WAS A HUNDRED AND
44% OF THE ELIGIBLE RESIDENTS
WERE REGISTERED AND SO THEY
WANTED TO GET TO THE CORE OF
HOW YOU COULD HAVE MORE. WILL
REGISTER VAN WERE RESIDENTS- BY
ABOUT 44% OVER WHAT IT SHOULD
BE PROBABLY MORE. SO WHAT THEY
WHAT IT WAS WAS EXPIRED
REGISTRANTS OUR OR INACTIVE-
REGISTRANTS PEOPLE WHO HAD-
UNDER MANDATE IF YOU HAVE. NOT
VOTED IN TWO CONSECUTIVE
FEDERAL ELECTIONS. YOU SHOULD
BE SENATE CONFIRMATION CARD AND
THEY HAVE NOT SENT OUT
CONFIRMATION CARDS IN OVER
TWENTY YEARS. SO BASICALLY
THAT'S WHAT THE FINDING WAS A
NOT LAWSUIT AND IT WAS SETTLED
THEY JUDICIAL WATCH ONE NOT
LAWSUIT SO WASN'T. FICTITIOUS
OR YOU KNOW PEOPLE SAYING
THINGS AND THEY'VE BEEN A
FANTASTICAL WAY IT WAS. VALID I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THE RECORD
SO IT WAS IT WAS NOT 20% OR
WHATEVER AND FIGURE I WAS NOT
IN. POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE
ONE POINT SIX MINUTES. FORTY
OFF THE ROLLS BECAUSE OF THAT I
AND I BELIEVE THERE JUST OVER
FIVE MILLION REGISTRANTS AN
ALLEY. OKAY I WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THE IT WASN'T NECESSARILY
THEIR INELIGIBLE TO VOTE IT WAS
THAT THEY HAD NOT VOTED IN IN A
COUPLE DIFFERENT LECTURE MAKING
THEM AN ELIGIBLE TO BE ON THE
VOTER ROLLS. THE FIVE BY
MANDATE OKAY I DON'T WANNA
BELIEVER THAT THANK ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU- WHAT WITH RESPECT TO
SENATOR BATES A SUGGESTION THAT
SIMPLY ANOTHER BLOCK BE ADDED
PRIOR TO THE PRIMARY IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE DMV- WE
WENT THROUGH THIS WITH THE-
ISSUE BECAUSE THE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY- THAT IT
WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE AT THIS
POINT FOR THE DMV TO. REPAIR
THEIR THEIR SYSTEM PRIOR TO THE
PRIMARY THE GENERAL IS THAT
RIGHT. SHOP I CAN'T SPEAK THE
DMV BUT THAT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING FOR THE A. I. P.
LEGISLATION. RIGHT IT IN
ANOTHER QUESTION. AND THAT THAT
WAS UP. REYES BY HER BATES UP
WHETHER IT'S NOW OR NEXT YEAR
ADDING ANOTHER BLOCK IT SAYS
I'M ALREADY REGISTERED TO VOTE
AND DO NOT WISH TO CHANGE MY
REGISTRATION WHICH IS I DON'T
I'M NOT SURE THAT THAT'S THE
BILL BUT BUT- I PATHETICALLY.
IF WE ADD ANOTHER BLOCK WHAT
WHAT WOULD THAT DO WITH THE
MEAN AND I'M NOT SOME OF THE
LOGISTICS OF IT I'M TALKING
ABOUT YOU SAID YOU'D FOCUS
GROUPS AND THAT KIND OF THING
WHAT WHAT WOULD THAT DO TO
VOTER BEHAVIOR. OR A REGISTERED
BEHAVIOR. I WOULD THINK I NEED
TO BE TESTED RIGHT ON BEFORE.
THE LAUNCH MOTOR VOTER THAN
LANGUAGE ON THE SCREENS WAS
TESTED- FIELD TESTED BY
ORGANIZATIONS AND PRESENTED-
LEGISLATURE INTO DEPRAVITY
GROUPS ON IT WHICH- TOOK
FEEDBACK AS CHANGE I THINK
WE'D- STILL BE OPEN TO MORE
CHANGES TO MAKE IT AND IMPROVE
IT. IS A JUST. A AGAIN I AM SO
WHAT'S THE BIG TO THE FACT IT
DOESN'T APPEAR THAT IF YOU'RE
ALREADY REGISTERED. AND YOU
WANT TO MAINTAIN YOUR
REGISTRATION THAT THAT THAT
EASILY DECIPHERED HERE I GET
THE I DO NOT WANT TO REGISTER
TO VOTE BUT IF YOU DON'T GET
PASSED. WORDS AS FOR UPDATE MY
VOTER REGISTRATION AT THAT. I
THINK THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD BILL FOCUS UPON.
ALL RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS THE
OTHER QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT
CENTER BATES THAT ARE MORE LIKE
YOU MAY CLOSE WELL I THANK YOU
FOR WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE A
VERY GOOD DEBATE AS WE TAKE A
LOOK AT A DEEPER DIVE INTO WHAT
IS CREATING THE WHIMS OF
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE MOTOR
VOTER LAW I WANT TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR IN RESPONSE TO
SENATOR HERTZBERG I DO NOT HAVE
AN ISSUE WITH TRUST WITH THE
DMV I HAVE BEEN HAVING BEEN A
DRIVER SINCE I WAS. EIGHTEEN
OLD THEY'VE TREATED ME WELL GOT
ONE TICKET NAY DIDN'T MESS UP
MY DRIVER'S LICENSE BACK I
THINK THERE IS ANY TO I IN THIS
STATE NOW WE KNOW THERE'S AN
INITIATIVE HAD BALLOT OF
PRIVATE HE IS A PRIVACY ISSUE
WITH THIS WHICH IS NOT REALLY
PART. OF WHAT THE LEGISLATION
CIVIC THEONE. BUT I THINK ARE
REQUIRING EVERY DE. SER TO VOTE
TRENT BID FROM THE DMB WHO'S
DOING WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE THE
VERY BEST JOB THEY POSSIBLY CAN
WITH A SHORT TIME LINE THAT WAS
MANDATED UPON THEM AND WE'VE
HEARD. ANONYMOUSLY FROM A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THAT.
DEPARTMENT THAT AGENCY THAT
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT THEY
WERE NOT IN FAVOR OF THE LAUNCH
TIME. WE HAVE AN ISSUE- AND WE
NEED TO ADDRESS IT AND I THINK
MY BILLS SPECIFICALLY WAS
LOOKING FOR THAT ANSWER AND I
CAME UP WITH A SIMPLER ONE SO
I. WOULD BE VERY OF. THE OF THE
OF. THIS HEARING WE TAKE THAT
FORWARD YEAH I CAN'T IMAGINE I
CAN SEE THE INDEPENDENT.
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY
BECAUSE THAT'S A PARTY
PREFERENCE. BUT JUST TO BE ABLE
TO SAY FOR THE BILL'S GOING
FORWARD BETWEEN THE PRIMARY I'M
ALREADY REGISTERED DON'T. ****
BECAUSE I WANT BE ABLE TO VOTE
IN THAT ELECTION AND IT WILL.
BE IF ALL. THEIR BELIEVE THAT
EVERY BODY. WHO WILL. FEEL COME
ALLUSION VOTE. PART OF. BLOCK
THE FREEDOM THAT WE ARE.
ACTUALLY ARE ENJOY IN THIS
GREAT NATION SOLD FOR ANYBODY
TO BE BLOCKED FROM THAT BECAUSE
OF THESE. WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE
CUTE COMPUTER GLITCHES OR
COMPUTER ERRORS ARE PROGRAMMING
PROBLEMS THAT NEEDS TO BE DEALT
DEALT WITH IMMEDIATELY. BEFORE
THAT PRIMARY AND THIS IS ONE
SIMPLE SOLUTION ARE BY ADDING A
BOX- TO THE S. THAT DOESN'T
CHANGE ANYTHING ANY OF THE
OTHER QUESTIONS DOESN'T CHANGE
THEM IN THE SLIGHTEST. WOULD BE
A GREAT BENEFIT OUGHT TO VOTER
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY. TO BE
PART OF THIS GREAT NATION AND
THAT THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND- PICKING AND
CHOOSING YOU WANT. TO COME UP
TO THE HOUSE BILL HOW OLD THE-
GOVERNMENT IN AN ACT OF EXPRESS
THE WISHES OF THE PEOPLE. SO
PLEASE CONSIDER THAT OUT ON
THOSE- POSITION THAT DO THAT
ARE YOU WILL BE I THINK
UPGRADE. NOT TOO. OLD FOR YOU
BEING A LEAD ON HOW WE ACTUALLY
HAVE OUR GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
REGISTERING PEOPLE. I WHAT I
CONSIDER TO BE IN A VERY
EFFICIENT BUT VERY FAIR AND
TRANSPARENT MANNER. EXAMINE
SOMEWHAT. MYSTERY DATE AT THE
BILL YET THAT IS. OF THIS BILL.
ONE OF THE LIMITATIONS
COMMITTEE MEETINGS AS WE DON'T
HAVE SCREENS WE DON'T HAVE- THE
ABILITY TO.BRING UP WEBSITE.
AB GO WAS APPLE. OPPORTUNITY BY
GOING TO THE DMV AND DOING A
TRANSACTION SO I'M I'M I'M VERY
GLAD THAT SENATOR. BYRD IT THIS
WEEKEND IT'S FRESH IN YOUR.
MIND BUT WHEN YOU THROUGH THE
PROCESS THIS IS. THE OLD BIRD
AND SO WE WERE HAVE DONE YEARS
IN FRONT OF EVERYBODY HERE SEE
THE BOXES AND SEE WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE DEALING WITH SO I WANT TO
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR.
BRINGING THAT UP. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO GET EVERYONE TO
REGISTER TO VOTE AT THAT THAT'S
NOT THE ARGUMENT- WITH WITH
THIS BILL- BUT- BUT- THE GOAL
IS CONVENIENCE. THE GOAL IS
USER FRIENDLY THE GOAL IS. A
TRYING TO BE DIGITALLY
INNOVATIVE AND RIGHT NOW IT'S
NOT IT'S A LACKING- USE THE
ABILITY FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND AND NOT GET
FRUSTRATED OR CONFUSED. AND SO
THAT'SWHAT WHAT WERE CLOSING
AND SO I APPRECIATE. THE
COMMENTS CENTER HERTZBERG- I
THINK IF THIS BILL NEEDS
ANYTHING BASED ON YOUR-
ARGUMENTS MAYBE SOME.
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH I
THINK THIS BILL SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD WE SHOULD BE. ASSISTING
OUR CONSTITUENTS IN A POSITIVE
WAY TO MAKE VOTING AND VOTER
REGISTRATIONS MUCH MORE
CONVENIENT AND THAT'S WHY I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON SB FIFTY
SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES. THANK THANK YOU SIR
MORE LUGGAGE OF QUESTIONS THAT
ARE PURCHASED APOLOGIZE OUT OF
ORDER HERE THE FIRST POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE IF I COULD.
I THINK THAT THE MESSAGE IS
BEEN RECEIVED BY THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE I THINK THAT
THEY I DIDN'T REALIZE AS YOU
QUESTIONS VERY GOOD INSTRUMENT
ABOUT. YOU'VE TESTED. AND FOCUS
GROUP IN A LIGHT AND SEEMS TO
ME THE FASTEST WAY TO IN THIS
CASE YOU CAN MAKE CHANGES THEY
DID. IT IS A RESULT HEARING
TODAY HAVE THE SECRETARY STATE
TAKE A LOOK AT THERE'S SOME
CONFUSION. A FIX IT AND BUT
ULTIMATELY FOCUSES WHICH IS MY
FOCUS IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
MOTOR VOTER ENACTED SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY THREE THANK
YOU- IS A WORKS AS BEST AS
POSSIBLE I THINK THAT WOULD BE
THE BEST COURSE OF ACTION. IS
SOMETIMES LEGISLATION ISN'T
ALWAYS THE ANSWER YOU'VE GOT
THE PEOPLE. RIGHT IN FRONT OF
YOU THAT CAN MAKE THE CHANGE
PRETTY QUICKLY THANK YOU. THE
LAST. THEY DID HAVE THIS BEFORE
US YES IT IS WELCOME THAT SAID-
I BELIEVE THERE MAY BE SOME
GROUNDS FOR AMENDMENTS THAT
BECAUSE WE CANNOT GET THEM
BEFORE US TODAY BUT I WOULD
MOVE THE BILL THAT WE MIGHT
MOVE IT ALONG AND HAVE A
AUTHORS WORK WITH THE CHAIR
TOWARDS SOME OF THE SUGGESTIONS
OF THE SUGGESTION TO YOU OF AND
I THINK THAT HAS MERIT AT LEAST
SO I WOULD MOVE THE BILL TO
KEEP IT ALIVE FOR THAT PURPOSE.
THANK YOU SIR NIELSEN I THINK
THERE'S A NUMBER DIFFERENT
CONST FLOAT AROUND ONE IS THE
ISSUE OF THOSE WHO ARE
INELIGIBLE TO VOTE ACTUALLY
REGISTERING AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
GOING TO THE DMV THE SECOND IS
PEOPLE BEING USED AT AND THE
THIRD IS. WHAT WE ARE NOT THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT. DELIBERATELY
TRYING TO MISTER WHO ARE TRYING
TO FRAUD THE SYSTEM. IN TERMS
OF THE ISSUE OF CONFUSION- I
THINK I'M GLAD YOU RACES I
DON'T THINK THE BILL DOES THAT
I THINK THE BILL IS AN OPT IN
OPT OUT KIND OF THING- BUT BUT
I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU BOTH BOTH SENATOR MORE
LIKE IT'S UNDER BATES TO
CLARIFY BECAUSE ANOTHER BLOCK
SAYING I'M ALREADY REGISTERED
AND I DON'T WANT TO SCREW
AROUND WITH- BUT ONCE IT LIKE
THAT. BUT I DON'T WANNA I DON'T
CHANGE MY ADDRESS OR PARTY
AFFILIATION THAT THAT MAY- MAY
BE SOMETHING WE NEED TO FURTHER
EXPLORE BUT HAVING SAID THAT
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION MA'AM
SECTOR IF YOU'D CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS.
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
NUMBER OF NUMBER NO. NIELSEN
NELSON I'M HERTZBERG. LEYVA
LEYVA KNOWN STERN STERN NO.
THREE EIGHT THREE ONE OF THE
BILL REMAINS THREE ONE. I'M I'M
SORRY IT STRUCK THAT. THE BILL
FAILS- ONE I THREE KNOWS THAT
THANK YOU. YES OF WE COULD MOVE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THEIR
MOTION. THE LEYVA THE ANSWER TO
THE CALL THE ROLL. I AM TOO SB
SIX EIGHTY FOUR AMBER AMBER I.
NIELSEN NIELSEN AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA LEYVA AYE
STERN STERN HI. IT'S NOT A ZERO